it's pretty clear what cocaine bear is
about but who's in it who's behind it
and why did this true story need to be
retold beyond the Bonkers premise here's
everything you need to know about
cocaine bear
cocaine bear was first announced in 2019
with the trade describing it as a unique
bear-driven horror comedy with heart
that's quite summery and since then
we've been expectingly waiting to see
the story of Pablo Escobar play out in
the big screen now we know exactly when
that big furry Predator will start
snorting and snarling and scaring its
poor victims Universal released the
first poster for the project in November
2022 one that pictured a black and white
image of a very coked up bear looking
ready to seriously mess some people up
the posters tagline reads get in line
and was accompanied by a release date
prepare to see the horrors and hilarity
of a drug-fueled man-eater when cocaine
bear crashes exclusively into theaters
on February 24th 2023
the plot of cocaine bear promises to be
absolutely wild according to the
Hollywood Reporter cocaine bear will
follow an oddball group of cops
criminals tourists and teens converging
in a Georgia Forest where a 500 pound
apex predator has ingested a staggering
amount of the white powder and goes on a
coke-fueled rampage seeking more blow
and blood cocaine bear will mix horror
and comedy together creating a movie
that'll deliver both cackles and Carnage
of course one of the biggest selling
points for the film is that it's based
on a true story according to Rolling
Stone in real life a man named Andrew C
Thornton decided to use his background
as paratrooper cop and lawyer along with
his own plane to smuggle cocaine from
Colombia into the U.S during one fateful
run he overloaded the plane and was
forced to toss packages of coke down
into the forest below that's when some
poor bear stumbled upon the nose candy
and decided to gobble down about 15
million dollars of the stuff needless to
say the bear overdosed as for Thornton
his fate was also pretty grisly
realizing he'd need to bail Thorn jumped
from his plane only his parachute didn't
open and some unlucky fellow found
Thornton dead on his driveway an elderly
gentleman had called the dispatch and
said that there was somebody in his yard
and he didn't look like he was moving
the story was reported on by the New
York Times and now this Larger than Life
tale is getting what promises to be an
even crazier big screen adaptation
just like the titular bear is absolutely
loaded with Coke cocaine bear is
absolutely loaded with Talent first up
there's Carrie Russell best known for
playing Russians by Elizabeth Jennings
in the Americans and the titular
character in GJ Abrams WB series
Felicity interestingly Russell won't be
the only Americans alum in the film and
she'll be joined by Margo Martindale who
won two Emmys for playing Russell's KGB
Handler in the aforementioned FX series
as well as Matthew Reese who starred in
the series as Russell's husband fellow
undercover spy Philip Jennings they'll
be accompanied by the late great Ray
Liotta who starred in films like
Goodfellas and Field of Dreams as the
actor passed away in May 2022 cocaine
bear will be the legendary actors final
film the movie also Stars Alden
ehrenreich of solo a Star Wars story
Fame O'Shea Jackson Jr from Straight
Outta Compton and Jesse Tyler Ferguson
of Modern Family you're safe Bears can't
climb trees of course I can
in keeping with its reported horror
comedy Vibe cocaine bear was originally
going to be directed by radio silence
the group comprised of Matt benonelli
open Tyler Gillette and Chad vallella
three guys who filmed similarly
hilarious yet scary films like ready or
not and scream 6. however now radio
silence is out and another director's
skill to Comedy is in cocaine bear will
now be helmed by the one and only
Elizabeth Banks on the acting side of
things you know Banks from The Hunger
Games franchise and the Pitch Perfect
series on the directing side of things
Banks has two movies under her
filmmaking belt Pitch Perfect 2 and
2019's Charlie's Angels in other words
we know for a 100 fact that Banks can
bring the laughs as for the Thrills
we're very interested to see what banks
can bring to the horror table as she
branches out from her usual genre
in addition to Elizabeth Banks cocaine
bear has quite a bit of talent sitting
behind the camera the film's producers
are absolute powerhouses when it comes
to creating zany mind-bending movies
Phil Lord and Chris Miller have been
involved with the project since 2019.
the two are perhaps best known for their
directing work having helmed films like
Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs 21
Jump Street and The Lego Movie they also
produced quite a few winners including
the Mitchells versus the machines and
Spider-Man into the spider-verse of
course they aren't the only ones
producing this cocaine fueled pick in
addition to Aditya suit and Max
Handelman Ryan Duffield will help bring
this movie to the big screen Duffield is
one of the most original filmmakers
working today having pen scripts for
titles like the babysitter underwater
and spontaneous Duffield is definitely
skilled at combining comedy with
jaw-dropping horror in other words he
seems like the perfect fit for this
insane project this probably won't come
as much of a shot but cocaine bear is
going to feature some drug use it's
right there in the title and once that
titular apex predator starts snorting
that coke things are going to get bloody
very very bloody after all movies that
feature very hungry bears Hollow titles
like Backcountry and Revenant tend to
get pretty intense and those guys
weren't even using when they decided to
hunt down some humans throw some nose
candy into the mix and it should come as
no surprise that cocaine bear has been
rated R for bloody violence and Gore
drug content and language throughout oh
man
[Music]